Ukraine's ambassador to the UK Valley
pristaiko was involved in that Heathrow
County agreed to come into the program
as well good to see you as always thanks
very much India for joining us what on
Earth is going on with the Iranians
we still have to investigate whether the
ships were actually bringing in the
ammunition which was reported by Sky if
it is so I wouldn't be surprised because
they were supporting the Russia for some
time and they were supplying much more
expensive and dangerous things like
drones
and they are in abundance right now
yesterday we don't 13 out of 15 being
sent our way so what it's telling me
that first of all the war is becoming
Global so more and more players are
getting in there picking up their sites
and second that's Russia is actually
running off everything including the
ammunition if it is again the reports
are true what difference will it make if
Iran is involved in this way
I believe they're making a huge huge
mistake aligning with Russia but seems
like they don't have any other choice
they're looking for ways to you know to
sell anything at least now also saying
that Russia is not not on advancement
technological they depend now on Iranian
things I guess that you will have to
talk to Iran we are doing it we have our
Embassy there where we're still
maintaining contacts with Iran they
denying anything including the drones
but surely we will step by step we will
bring them understanding that that's not
the site the the wrong side they picked
so Ukraine has reached out to Iran to
say what's going on
they always say no it's not us if
anything you will find in Russians
Russians deposit this was maintained by
us because we supplied it's like long
long long time ago for different
contracts just before the war all of
this but unfortunately these ships if
it's true that they came they can tell
that there was before the words now
means as we see yeah both of them are
Pariah States Russia and Iran so perhaps
you can see their allegiance there what
if China gets involved
China is playing a very uh careful game
you see that they came recently with
their sorts of offer for the peace and
it's not not nothing news it's very
neutral position trying to please
everybody else but that's actually we
that's what we expect from China to stay
neutral in this conflict to try to
understand what we're trying what what's
not against China we have our enemy
Chinese not
do you feel that China will stay neutral
they will try to stay neutral because
they have so much dependent first of all
on international law and they're always
saying that the the territorial
integrity that's the key for everything
the sovereignty of the Nations and
second they are so interdependent with
the rest of the world it's not like
Russia which only say in oil and look at
in the prices down the economists are
suffering tremendously China is involved
in all the economies around the globe so
I understand they get the message and
the third message they received that if
they do something stupid that is the
whole big Coalition of Western Nations
to come to the help
the other issue though of course as far
as China getting involved is concerned
is that they have a big influence in
Eastern Africa with countries that at
the moment have remained neutral if
China does get involved that would
change significantly well I agree I
agree with you but don't forget that
Soviet Union also had this this
influence and now lavro was running
around these nations of Africa trying to
get support and if you look at the last
last vote in in un there's not much he
managed to together because Nations also
having their own interests and they
understand that their well-being all the
nations young Nations is actually
depends on respect to the borders to the
civilian to the entire Integrity
Territorial and that's exactly what's
threatened now with Ukrainian conflict
um talk to me about what about what's
been going on with this Nordstrom two
pipelines
um suggestions coming out of um the
United States New York Times have done
an investigation and they say a
pro-ukrainian group was responsible for
blowing up these pipelines yeah Almighty
ukrainians yeah I don't believe that
this is anything at least as of now to
be true even Russians are telling us
some some rubbish what if it's not
rubbish if it's not if it's investigated
we will see
would they have had the authority if it
is true
um I mean it could be that President
zolenski didn't know anything about it
it could be that he sanctioned what
happened if that is the case
what impact do you think that would have
on the support for Ukraine so far we
understand that would please Russians
than anybody else because for over the
years they wanted to show that everybody
is dependent on their oil and gas if
anything happens was was the supply
everybody will freeze down to dust
that's why actually we're making even
the advertisement this year that's Old
Europe old is dying because of the of
the frost and everything they cut Supply
in Ukraine so the next logical step
would be to cut half of Supply somewhere
else that is why in my opinion just the
half of these pipelines were blown up I
understand that Mr ambass but what about
if it was um Ukraine supported this is a
bit mature to discuss things like what
would happen if we believe that nothing
there is no now our involvement there
I'm not just talking about technically
how difficult it is to do it I'm just
telling that's totally against our own
interest and actually even through the
war which we had seven years we were
still maintaining the supply to Europe
through our pipelines of Russian gas
just to show
how reliable Ukrainian Supply is
what's life like in Ukraine at the
moment you know we've got a little bit
of snow here and everybody's petrified
of the snow the temperatures the
um the weather in Ukraine bitterly colds
at the moment how are people coping
given that you don't have the energy
supplies that you need we we can say
safely that we went through the the
harshest time of our winter since
somewhere in the middle of February
usually and our our Network survived we
just once had a total blackout but
because of the we are supplied mostly by
nuclear energy we are second only to
France in nuclear generation we managed
to get through it and all the support
which we need we had and don't forget
that 8 million of us already outside of
the of the nation and half our economy
is not working so the combination of all
these factors allowed us to get through
this winter
and on a more positive note I hear that
you're organizing a rather a flashy
concert at Wembley we recognizing with
you and you know we're quite happy that
you actually won second place and we're
logically given the chance to to run the
the Eurovision yeah no I'm thinking
about the Wembley concert or the Wembley
yes we're doing so many things where you
write this this year that's a huge thing
we wanted to do something like on a Live
Aid style 1985 which brought the
attention of the whole world to the
problem in Africa we believe that
something can be can be done again to
just to tell people the story of Ukraine
and remind them after the Year by that
time and a half of a year of the
conflict I believe they will be great
we're reaching out to the many A-Class
artists we will see okay well we wish
you uh well in that endeavor it's always
great to see you thank you very much
thank you for joining us